whether you had a giddy or a bad year I
have good and bad news for you the good
news is tomorrow's a new day the bad
news is if you the today version of you
doesn't change one thing about you today
tomorrow is going to be the same over
and over and over again see I tell you
today because the message I want to
cover with you today is to show you how
to crack the code to one of your own
limiting beliefs that's been holding you
back from living the life that you want
to live what's so interesting with so
many people that I mentor I sat down
with somebody yesterday going through
their business plan and after an hour
and a half of conversation with this
with this grown man who's a successful
individual but he's been plateauing at a
level it took us an hour and a half away
until there was an emotional breakdown
and the conversation was about a deep
deep limiting beliefs it's one limiting
beliefs that was holding this man back
and he had to address it and there's
only one person that can crack the code
to your limiting belief and that's you
I'll show you the system but only one
person can do something about it so you
can either live this life for another 40
50 60 70 years however long you're going
to live and just be the same thing all
over again another your all over again
another all over again
or you can make the decision to say I
want to live the life to put the full
capacity life of me I don't want to
crack this code simple as that so we're
going to go through that here together
so how to break the curse of your
limiting beliefs few things you got to
know about life right we got issues with
faith that we struggle with we have
family friendship relationship marriage
we have finance business health and
politics now on each one of these you
may have a limiting belief because think
about it there are people you ever your
people that you know will brag about the
fact that they are you know very good in
their health and they have six-packs and
they have good bodies and you workout 7
times a week and you see them showing
their legs and they do all this stuff
and they're in such good shape right no
one in the bank account no good personal
life no good marital life not a good
faith but they have an incredible body
why is that well because they don't have
limiting beliefs in their health but
they do have limiting
beliefs in other areas of your life I
don't know what your limiting belief is
in what area but I promise you there's a
limiting belief that's holding you back
in each one of the areas let's give you
an idea one could be faith you could be
somebody that grew up in a church and I
hear this happen all the time the pastor
gets up one day and says you know I've
been having an affair with somebody in
the church da da da and I'm turned
stepping down and all of a sudden you
say I will never go to a church ever
again that is a limiting belief because
I'm an event took place to you when you
were 16 years old and your parents were
so disappointed and you were devastated
and now you don't believe in God because
you based everything of your faith was a
vertical relationship and you were
disappointed by horizontal because
somebody Ron you'll let you down so that
is a limiting belief and you need to
crack the code to see you you don't
believe there's another God or you're an
atheist you're an agnostic or whatever
our churches I just want to make money
because I remember one time we give this
pastor money he came on a Bentley and it
came it doesn't matter I don't know your
limiting belief but if you have a faith
issue you have a limiting belief you
they can address and if it's only it's
important to you you'll be able to crack
the code of your family friendship
relationship marriage so let's look at
that one you may be afraid of having
kids why because your mom or dad wasn't
a good mom and she left or he left and
you're afraid that if you have a kid
you're gonna be like that and you know
it's going to hurt you and you're afraid
to have kids because you were hit and
abused when you were a kid growing up
and you're afraid that maybe you're
going to do that and no one knows about
that but it's a feared that you've been
arrested in to prison no one knows it
relationship your parents got a divorce
you're afraid of getting married because
if you do get married
what if somebody gets a divorce or if
you're a woman and every time you date a
man and all of a sudden you realize this
is a good guy that could be married you
cheat on them and you go with somebody
else because you don't want to break you
don't want it to get too serious because
what if you get serious and a 17 years
later when your parents were married
your father left and broke all that
stuff it's so deep but it is a limiting
belief that's holding you back if it is
that's the area friendships you have a
hard time keeping friends because one of
your friends that was your best friend
ended up dating your boyfriend at that
time and you have a hard time trusting
friendships or you had a father that
left save a hard time trusting men all
your life where you had a mother that
said all these negative things about you
and she doesn't believe in you and all
that stuff so you have a hard time
working with other
woman in your life because there was
something in your life that's a limiting
belief that's stopping you from working
with those people in the right
relationship marriage could be the same
thing lots of them finance you grew up
in a family where your father worked
very hard and all of a sudden he lost
everything that he had it would
devastate a living in three different
homes so you think money sucks and
anybody that works that hard should have
stayed home either my dad won that's a
limiting belief you think money is
terrible you have a family that you grew
up poor and you saw your mom and dad
struggle over money so you're afraid of
money you're scarcity every time you go
anything going to lose everything gap so
you hoard all your money you cover all
your money because that's a limiting
belief that you've been living with for
a while and unless you crack the code
you're gonna live with that forever
money so you either don't deserve it you
make 180 thousand dollars a year but you
really only think you pay your 60 so
you're being overpaid so you take that
120 that you're making and you waste it
on cars jewelry everything three years
later you lose everything again because
your limiting belief is a 60 man I'm
getting over paid these people don't
even know I'm not worth 180 there is a
limiting belief problem there another
one is health right you grew up in a
family people generally didn't take care
of their health so you kind of will eat
whatever it is cheese cake sweets late
nights you don't work out you don't
exercise your parents didn't work out
nobody exercise somebody did somebody
got hurt exercises and not good all this
other stuff so you don't exercise
politics you hate Republicans because
your parents hate Republicans because a
president that was a president 28 years
ago that did one law or one thing that
they change and your father says I hate
Ronald Reagan because Ronald Reagan
wasn't fair to immigrants he's the worst
president of all time we're not
Republicans in my family so my family
were Hispanic we're Democrats were
african-american we're Democrats
we're Middle East we're Democrats as
what we are or and I grew up in a family
am i I saw my mom or my dad they were on
welfare all the time I was Section eight
taking advantage of everything and you
know they weren't really working they
could have worked I cannot stand the
communistic system I hate everything
about communism because everybody abuses
a system to get money that I thought
that I just cannot stand that I don't
want to have anything to do with
Democrats because I'm a Republican or
you grew up in a family that there was
so much fight about politics you don't
even want to talk about politics because
you're afraid of it there is a limiting
belief
with something to do with politics to
you if you don't have that challenge
don't worry about it but if you do
there's a limiting belief in what is it
you got to crack the code in that if
it's important to you so now the
challenge with limiting beliefs is this
most of the time there is the real truth
right the real truth of whatever one of
these beliefs that you may have and then
there is your truth your truth is not
the real truth your truth is what you
have been self sabotaging yourself
you've been self sabotaging yourself all
your life that has become a truth but
it's not the truth it is your truth you
know if you keep telling yourself a lie
over and over and over and over and over
again you could believe that lie but
it's true to you even though it's a lie
in reality if I tell myself 2+2
the real answer is 4 but I say 2 plus 2
is 7 and I keep saying that for 20-30
years guess what I really believe 2 plus
2 is 7 but it's not the real truth so
what does this mean to you so what is
your truth about money you got to write
it down what is your truth about
business
you think businessmen are all greedy
well you're never going to get have
money you're never going to have money
you think rich people are rich because
they took advantage of somebody else if
you really believe that you're never
going to have money if you think all men
cheat men aren't going to cheat in your
life if you keep thinking all men cheat
if you think you know women are this
woman you're not going to find that girl
unless if you crack that code and stop
self sabotaging yourself and hurting
yourself on the way of your life now
let's continue let's give you if I went
too fast you can watch this again ok so
now next limiting belief statements
typically a limiting belief statement is
a very simple statement that you make
you'll typically say say something like
I can't do X because of why I can't get
married because my parents thought that
that that that I can't become a
millionaire because all rich people suck
I can't go out there and do this because
of that thought that the limiting belief
statement another one is I'm not good
enough
right I don't believe in God I don't
believe in marriage really exists I
don't believe in you know keeping a
strong diet I think should
everything I don't believe in having my
finances in order I don't believe in
saving because you live once so you
should spend all your money because
that's what your family then should
spend all your money because you don't
believe in that right I don't need
anyone's help that's a very big limiting
belief people that thing I don't need
anybody self I'm a girl I don't need a
man in my life I don't need anybody's
help yeah you're probably not gonna find
a man that wants to stay married to you
because he wants to feel needed I'm a
guy I don't need any woman's help I'm on
mine you're probably not gonna find a
woman that is gonna stay with you
because she also wants to feel needed I
don't need anybody's help in business I
can do it all on my own
you're probably not going to find people
that want to be in business with you I
don't need it it doesn't matter if you
if you have a statement they say I don't
need anyone's help that's a limiting
belief another one's not my fault a
limiting belief it's not my I didn't do
it he did it she did it's now my faults
my wife's a husband my mom my dad my
brother my sister I had a conversation
with somebody on a conference call was
today today's what Wednesday Tuesday
morning had a conversation with somebody
and somebody said something to me on the
conference call I said listen I totally
understand that that may be a truth but
what I like to do with my life that I
had to graduate this back in 2004 is to
understand instead of saying it's not my
fault is to understand what can I do
with this situation myself to have
improved it do I do I have to voice my
opinion you have to say something to
have to act I have to look at my choices
but if I sit there and I let it happen I
don't do something myself you can't say
it's that person's fault it's your fault
so it's responsibility that's the
limiting belief what if I fail what if
it doesn't work what if this marriage
doesn't work what if I can't do it what
if this limiting belief statements if
you start from there positive one
instead of a limiting belief maybe you
know a imagine if like what if imagine
if I could make you imagine if there's
some time we go back to what if I feel
what if it doesn't work what if I'm not
good enough what if I'm not smart enough
limiting belief what if I'm not what if
I'm not what if I'm not what if I'm not
right those are limiting belief
statements make a list of some of your
limited
yeah now next one we've heard this in
other places before generational curses
that whether they are true or not okay
let's just say their note they're not
true okay that's great
maybe you need to tell yourself that but
sometimes people tend to follow the
exact footsteps of their mom or dad
whether it's good or bad sometimes the
bad we tend to continuously do because
it's a generational curse that keeps
continuously happening I'm ASA Patrick
you know it's generational curse stuff
is not the truth really hmm well if you
look at the generational curse if you
look at a kid that has played ball
you'll generally see the kid may also
play ball and the father play ball and
continuously will go down right Steph
Korea's father played his brother played
Eli Manning Peyton Manning you know
Archie is that Archie Manning Archie
Manning there's a there's a there's a
generational trend there that's not a
curse that's a trend there but you also
see it with some curse that takes place
holding grudges if you notice people
that hold a grudge heavily there's
typically somebody in that lineage of
their family that may hold a grudge they
may have had a relative or a mom or a
father I won't talk to that person ever
again that's holding a grudge but
there's something there so why are you
holding a grudge so you may ask yourself
who my family held grudge why am i
continuing this holding grudge to I want
my kids to also keep holding grudges
name it's not really a big deal to hold
a grudge well do you want to go 17 years
without talking to your brother do you
want to go 12 years without talking to
that best friend of yours that you guys
were best of friends he's successful
you're successful it's not like get some
negative habits both of you are
successful balance you're talking to
that person I don't want to talk to this
person I don't want to talk to that
person that's holding grudges with
people next money that's a big
generational curse you'll notice a trend
if you write the lineage father
grandfather how would they financially
are you continuing that tradition as
well financially good or bad why why do
you think you also have to continue that
this is not to blame them at all this is
that eventually under generational
the good news is that can be stopped and
it's normally stopped by one person that
becomes the hero for the future
generations of the family when that one
person decides to stop a generational
curse so you're spending Cabot's how
many of it is similar to your mom or
your dad how do you horde you do this
where did that come from
you got to ask those questions alcohol
sometimes you see a some drinks father
drank grandfather drink alcohol come
home I'm going to drink I'm going to do
this and it's not a big deal initially
and next thing you know two beers three
beers then hard liquid and everyday then
all the time then it's just making a
fool out of yourself you lost the job
lose relationships you do all these
other things it's a generational curse
that could be taking place breaking the
law sometimes you see hey my father's in
prison my brothers in prison my
grandfather's in prison so you go into
prison why do you need to continue that
as well that's a generational curse that
you're continuing sex married yet having
five girlfriends okay you look at your
father did that yes that may be a
generational curse that's passing down
right same with one mother your mother
maybe would hold it back from your
father and say from you no I haven't had
sex with your father for six months so
you do the same to your husband that
doesn't help the marriage odd right you
know I don't care if this this distance
that we're just not going to do this
that's also something could be passed on
because you saw one of the behaviors of
somebody so you're continuing that as
well it may not be the real truth but
it's your true drugs see that how common
that is smoking pot they smoke pot
ecstasy coke hard drugs drugs it doesn't
matter you'll see that trend taking
place as well next one is racism you see
a lot of that that's a generational
curse and let me tell what I mean by
racism it's you know oh you have to
marry a Hispanic person because we're
Hispanic you have to marry somebody
that's also Hispanic okay we don't marry
white people we don't marry black people
we don't marry middle Easterns we don't
marry this that's a generational curse I
grew up in a family that hey you know
you have to marry somebody that's a
middle-eastern I married a Caucasian
girl from Great Britain so I married
right and you know that that didn't look
out hear you what all my friends oh my
goodness you married in
American made somebody you should have
seen the reaction of my friends at our
wedding
you got all Middle Eastern hairy people
on one side you got all these Caucasian
blue-eyed green eyed people on the other
side they're looking at each end there's
no way in the world this is going to
work out okay that is a generational
curse of racism that could take place it
could be slighted not it's not even a
big deal but many times I heard somebody
the other day say I don't like working
with white people you know because I
believe the white man has this and white
man has that and white man has this well
that that's probably going to be passed
on to your kid you know white people
have been suppressing all this others I
don't like working with black people
because black people dis on black people
that and you see what they did crime on
all this others I don't want to work
with Hispanics because they just want to
do it I don't want to work with you you
may not even know it because every time
we say racism the first thing we think
about is african-american that's not the
case at all it has nothing to do with
african-american it has to do with a
complete different thing that you may
have I grew up you know you look at the
Russians Turkish you know all religions
or you don't marry this religion you
don't marry that that that a part of
that has to do with racism and then
obviously abuse and we're talking about
abuse tongue it's either verbal abuse
where you saw somebody lashing out on
your wife your your your father lashed
out on your on your mother so you do
that to your wife or you saw your mother
last shot on your father and you do that
or your father lashed out on you your
doing that as well sometimes this is
more painful than a pow pow this is
sometimes a lot more painful than you
giving your kid a Papa because this
stays this is a very the tongue ism it's
a very powerful weapon believe me it's a
lot more powerful than a baseball bat a
lot more powerful than any of that stuff
because a baseball bat you get a 1 you
get over it this stays right here and
right here that leaves a scar so you got
to write down what statements have been
made to you they've been lingering with
you from your mother or your father I
had to do this 11 12 years ago to
experience that and was that the real
truth or was that her statement was that
his statement right or is it my truth
and that's not the real truth right and
then the other type is domestic you know
physical abuse you've seen some you know
fathers abuse the wife or mother
uses the the husband and there's fights
and abuse and physical and you see that
on a kid grows up Lincoln that's that's
normal every one of these can be
addressed by the way let me add
something else to this as well that
kinda has to do with it it's slightly
different is your personal device
management and I'll explain to you what
I mean by this most people don't if
right now think about the most
embarrassing thing you've done in the
last month that no one knows about you
think about that one thing that you have
a vice that no one knows about if that
vice all of a sudden became public
writing on Facebook and social media how
would you and I react embarrassed right
you have no idea how many of us are
being held back by a vice it's a secret
no one knows it what is that vice a
secret habit that you have that no one
knows you do a certain drug alcohol a
mistress online porn it doesn't matter
what it is you have a vice that whole
you're absolutely lazy no one knows
about it you sleep in you slouch no one
knows about it you you binge you eat and
no one knows about it later that no
one's right just sit down a cheesecake
chocolate on ice cream I don't know how
I gained weight it's a vice no one knows
about it listen you can only fool the
world for so long with your vice until
the Vice catches up to all of us all of
us and by the way don't think for a
moment there are these perfect people
that don't have an advice no one is free
of this like this is not something that
the perfect church-going people don't
struggle with no no no no every one of
us struggles with this everyone's closet
has some skeletons in it except some
have a lot of skeletons some have a few
but everyone's got skeletons in it
there's sooner you address your vice and
you drop those to vice or one you're
dealing dealing with it kind of sets you
free a little bit more to get away from
a curse that's holding you back but you
got to sit down and do this exercise and
find out for yourself
so now question becomes so what do I do
how do what I do this whole thing here
that I'm dealing with I would suggest
you watch the video yeah but these are a
few things I would tell you one you
gotta be real with yourself you cannot
be yes yourself this is no [ __ ] in
here with this here you cannot do that
you cannot sit here and tell yourself oh
I'm okay everything's okay it's not if
you fool yourself we can fool people for
the rest of our lives the most difficult
person to fool is the man in the mirror
and let me tell you the man in the
mirror is the only person in your life
you're gonna have to live with for the
rest of your life now your wife now your
husband now your kids now your mom now
your dad now your best friend nobody
only the man in the mirror and a man in
the mirror does not hold back because he
or she knows everything about you
everything about you
the sooner you're real with yourself -
sooner you're liberated you know how
many people live with handcuffs and
shackles that are non-existent but
they're holding them back you know how
many people billions of people
these are non-existent imaginary
handcuffs and shackles simply because we
don't want to be real with ourselves and
say I have some issues I got address man
I got to work on some of these issues
that I'm better yet get frustrated with
yourself you need to feel some emotions
right now if you're not this is a waste
of a video you need to get frustrated
with yourself you need to get emotional
with yourself you need to cry possibly
you need to feel the pain those things
need to happen the this there is no
intention of this up you know Izzy you
really need to feel that emotion on your
belly while you're going through this
there's got to be someone knowing is
some emotional some pain some
frustration being felt that's number one
first things first
second thing take the time out when I
say time out I'm not talking two weeks
off a week off or weekend off you need a
day away from everybody turn this damn
thing off sometimes right take a day and
turn this thing off everything not just
notifications turn it off get away sit
down a timeout with you and you I'm not
talking spouse or anybody you the only
person
you gotta figure out to crack the code
with is you get away from everybody
number one no BS number two take your
time on number three go on the website I
have to go through these questions
eleven years ago
twelve years ago and I've talked about
this over and over and over again
go take the ultimate self-discovery
questionnaire it's free you don't pay
for it it is free it's on my website
link will be here if it's not your goal
my website Patrick David calm take the
ultimate self-discovery questionnaire
let me just put it to you this way I
launched this question or a few months
ago the first three months three hundred
people took it do you know how many
people have taken the last two months
twenty-six thousand twenty-five thousand
and change have taken it the last two
months from a hundred and thirty
countries and if I showed you an amount
of emails we're getting with emotional
emails you'd be amazed by but go take
that questionnaire with your time out
get emotional get frustrated last one
the book go get 225 lots for doing
impossible here's a copy of it look I
don't make money on these things I may
make a buck or two on these books I'm
not selling this book to make a living I
run a financial firm half these videos
listen we had somebody from Facebook
that came today people are sneaking up
in our office right now left and right
every day people are coming from Korea
from other parts of the world that are
wanting to come and visit us just to sit
down and talk business Malaysia Dubai
South America they're just coming here
they're finding out our address and
they're just coming and visiting us
I run a financial firm I don't need to
make another dollar or two on a book but
this book is a simple book I'm
recommending to you I wrote this book
twenty-five laws for doing the
impossible the reason why this goes with
this is because you've got three phases
you need to go through number one you
got to recreate yourself
number two you got to identify your
cause number three you got to go make
history specific it's in this book you
can buy it on Amazon Barnes & Noble it's
all over the place you can find it go
get the book so one no BS be real to
take otama three ultimate self discovery
question of four read a book you can
read it in one sitting and five once you
go through that make a big bold move
shock everybody change the look of your
eyes let people see a new set of eyes
because you have finally faced yourself
and you've addressed your curse you
dressed your vice you've addressed your
issues you are no longer embarrassed of
yourself
you no longer have nothing to hide you
have breaking the handcuffs and shackles
you're free you are free and guess what
the good news is tomorrow's a new day
and guess what else is the good news
tomorrow is going to be an incredible
day moving on this year's going to be an
incredible year my life's going to be an
incredible life I'm going to have the
most incredible relationships I'm going
to have the most incredible friendships
I want to make incredible amount of
money I'm gonna go see the world I'm
gonna have fun I'm gonna take care of my
health I'm gonna have a relationship
with a god or a higher power I'm gonna
feel good about this cat so with the 75
to 90 years that I have in this
existence I'm gonna give value back and
leave a legacy in the world and they're
gonna remember the mark I left in this
world you go do that that's the time to
go do it you remember I don't make any
money from doing anything like this with
the video I give $50,000 offered to go
speak at people I'm not making any money
of disappointing doing this video for
you take this message whatever part of
the world you are nobody needs to know
where you are but you know where you are
while you're watching this could be two
o'clock in the morning while you
watching this could be midnight right
now everyone's asleep
you're watching us you're getting
emotion you're feeling the pain dude
right now
don't set this thing aside this life
thing is very exciting like this it goes
gray hair like this it goes I look at my
leg today I was exercising I went to the
gym in the morning I looked at my skin
on the bottom of my ankle I saw the
veins that I used to make fun of my mom
and dad with the veins I have him now
never had those veins it's poppin' now
what happened with that this guy is
getting older and he's got an expiration
date
he got 300 years to live I got anywhere
between 17 or 90 years to live so do you
you think got a lot of time to change
you don't start today make that decision
today if you have to watch the video
again you didn't take notes grab a
notepad and pen go through it again
make these five points that you got to
go through and then from there look when
you're done with this if you're shaking
a little bit if you're emotional a
little bit and from there you you you
come out and it's like this very sense
of calm Ness about you and you you kind
of like whoa well I'm not cocky or
arrogant at all but I feel good about
life and myself I am very excited about
life that's not supposed to be and when
you do this exercise let me know you can
comment on the bottom we can share this
video with your peers for them to
experience it as well you know let me
know about the experience you have for
you I really love to hear the stories I
get tens of thousands of messages now on
Facebook so I can't get back to
everybody but if you comment on the
bottom up generally be able to see it
you can comment on the website Facebook
video you to wherever it's at or you can
send private messages to us on Facebook
and we'll be able to hear that as well
anyways thanks for watching and go make
that bold move in your life
you